[Musique]
José Legault bonsoir bonsoir on en
reparle forcément parce que c'est le
même atteint la rencontre Trudeau Lego
entre autres la santé mais c'est quand
même le gros morceau de cette rencontre
là on va parler d'immigration également
et peut-être d'autres sujets aussi je
vous fais entendre monsieur Trudeau
encore aujourd'hui et Monsieur Duclos
ministre de la Santé fédérale
aujourd'hui on revient
je pense que les Canadiens veulent
clairment voir les améliorations dans
leur service de santé nous en tant que
gouvernants fédéral on est là à pour
travailler avec les provinces pour
investir plus avec les provinces mais
comme j'ai dit depuis le début on doit
avoir des améliorations dans les
services pour les Canadiens
mais moi je suis que le temps que j'ai
avec mes collègues ministres de santé
est excellent je pense quand monsieur
Trudeau et monsieur Legault ça va
continuer à bien se passer me fait de
très grandes choses au cours des
dernières années puis l'agenda est bien
remplie demain moi je suis sûr qu'on va
arriver à une belle entente en 2023 ça
va demander de faire les choses
différemment mais on est habitué de
faire différemment les choses avec des
collègues des promesses et
ça fait 110 panel où on parle de ça les
gens se disent
pour vous m'expliquer Alec et José
qu'est-ce qu'a en tête quand être le
fédéral parce qu'on dit conditions pour
faire un raccourci quand ils disent on
veut pas rajouter de l'argent dans un
système brisé d'abord quelles experts
quelle expertise ils ont un dans la
gestion du réseau santé et deux
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont en tête parce
qu'ils ont des choses en tête avec
de ce qu'on sait on n'est pas dans les
discussions on sait qu'ils veulent
davantage de partage des données entre
les provinces pour qu'on puisse par
exemple s'inspirer d'une autre province
si on se rend compte qu'en Ontario
le temps d'attendre le temps d'attente
aux urgences pour une chirurgie de la
hanche etc les meilleurs mais comment
ils font en Ontario pour arriver à ses
résultats là le fait de se comparer
pourrait forcer les provinces à
s'améliorer dans certains secteurs donc
on veut une réédition de données qui
permettrait d'avoir un espèce de tableau
de bord un peu comme christianisme pour
le Québec ça existe mais pour tout oui
mais le Québec participe à peu près
jamais à ce type de partage de données
là on dit que c'est pas de leurs
affaires à Ottawa on n'a pas besoin
d'envoyer les chiffres donc quand on les
fait c'est des organismes qui essaient
de prendre des données qui sont
publiques mais Québec les envoient pas
là pour être capable de compiler le
généralement
il les envoie sur le web parce que Dubé
il y a quand même
le tableau de bord qu'on peut suivre
ouais mais ça c'est assez nouveau
seulement donc d'avoir quelque chose un
système un peu plus élaboré de partage
de données entre les provinces puis
ensuite on veut être capable d'aller
chercher un peu de crédit politique de
dire on a investi tant pour ça a permis
d'embaucher les infirmières ça va vous
permettre de diminuer les listes
d'attente donc donner de l'argent qui va
dans un secteur la santé mentale
entre on donne
le temps pas juste être un guichet
automatique qui va dire on ne contribuer
à améliorer le système alors
ottawaimerait ça aussi pouvoir dire ça
que l'argent du fédéral ne soit pas
englouti dans le budget général de la
santé mais qui soit dédié à des choses
précises qu'on puisse dire grâce à
l'argent du fédéral nous avons fait ceci
cela José
c'est ça oui et ben oui il y a vraiment
un jeu et un jeu politique sur la forme
bien entendu bon je sais Trudeau il
détient les cordons de la bourse donc
par définition il a le gros bout du
bâton
mais en même temps il existe une chose
qui s'appelle la Loi canadienne sur la
santé donc oui la santé de juridiction
provinciale mais il y a une loi
canadienne sur la santé qui si elle
n'existait pas Dieu seul sait dans quel
état encore pire on serait d'ailleurs
encore plus de privatisation gratuités
universalité
et malgré ça il y a énormément on est
rendu dans un système au Québec à
plusieurs vitesses il y a des gros
problèmes il a pandémie vraiment mise à
jour tout ça et ça c'est l'avantage que
Justin Trudeau a sur le plan politique
c'est que là maintenant le roi nu
c'est-à-dire des différents systèmes de
santé au Canada et nus et celui du
Québec est plus nu que les autres on a
vu les derniers chiffres aussi sur les
urgences le Québec et le cancre au
Canada etc alors je pense que oui il y a
ça sur le sur le plan politique mais sur
le fond il y a une inquiétude à Ottawa
que le système de santé au Canada malgré
les juridictions provinciales est en
train de manger
solide coule sur le plan de sa
réputation et donc je pense que c'est
pour ça qu'on exige plus d'efficacité
mais oui mais ça va être ça va tout être
ça va être un bras de fer parce que
exiger l'efficacité je veux bien mais
encore une fois on peut demander de
l'information on peut demander que telle
somme ça soit publié ça soit public que
le fédéral a contribué pour X pour
engager les infirmières par exemple mais
comment faire pour que ça marche mieux
le gouvernement fédéral sauf erreur pas
beaucoup d'expertise là-dedans j'oser là
ben voilà voilà ça va ça va être ça le
problème et d'ailleurs on entendait
Christian Dubé ce matin le ministre de
la santé au Québec dire moi ça te fera
cette phrase là elle est importante de
dire il manque pas d'infirmières au
Québec donc pas d'infirmière au Québec
on sait que c'est un problème
d'organisation c'est un problème de
condition de travail c'est un problème
de de du privé qui vient vampiriser le
public et le public qui se laisse
vampiriser donc lorsque le fédéral parle
de de payer pour embaucher plus
d'infirmières la problématique est
peut-être là non parce que je reçois de
plus en plus de courriels de gens
excédent et je les comprends je leur
porte-parole ce soir en disant l'arrêter
de toujours répéter les mêmes choses
là-dessus on veut des résultats à des
gens qui attendent pour ceci pour cela
Alec alors les deux ordres de
gouvernement sentent cette pression là
aussi faut que demain peut-être pas
demain mais il faut que vite en 2023 on
sent que ça avance parce qu'on tourne en
rond on peut
ouais et c'est peut-être le seul point
sur lequel je t'intrudo et j'arrive du
coup peuvent marquer des points on en
met déjà beaucoup d'argent dans le
système de santé les provinces en
mettent le transfert fédéral en santé a
beaucoup augmenté depuis une dizaine
d'années peut pas vraiment dire qu'on a
vu beaucoup de résultats en fait c'est
payé que ça que jamais alors c'est sûr
que de dire on vous refait un chèque là
on vous refait un chèque de 28 milliards
par année les provinces on vous le donne
est-ce que les gens vont dire waouh ça
va s'améliorer le demain matin ça va
être bon pas nécessairement donc quand
l'Ottawa qui je suis d'accord ne pas
vraiment de faire dans les champs de
compétences des provinces devraient les
provinces de gérer mais quand j'étais
Trudeau il faut que ça s'améliore puis
on va essayer de trouver une manière de
le faire avec les provinces les gens se
disent ouais un peu raison que depuis
une coupe d’année on peut pas dire que
ça s'est amélioré vraiment c'est le seul
la seule levier qu'ils ont c'est de dire
ça s'améliore pas donc même si on vous
donne de l'argent et que vous faites ce
que vous voulez avec ça marche pas donc
est-ce qu'on peut essayer quelque chose
de nouveau c'est peut-être pas une bonne
tactique sur le plan de juridictionnelle
parce qu'ils ont pas beaucoup
d'expertise mais sur le plan politique
les gens enregistres quand même que
c'est vrai que ça fait pas mal d'argent
qu'on met là dedans qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de raisons ce sera une des un
des grands sujets demain lors du
tête-à-tête le goût Trudeau il y aura
l'immigration mais on s'attend à ce que
la santé soit peut-être le gros sujet
José
oui la santé
les transferts
pour être pour être plus précis et ça
c'est la grande demande mais il n'y a
pas que ça évidemment l'immigration ça
aussi c'est c'est un désaccord quoi que
c'est un désaccord qui s'est à moins
gris considérablement depuis l'élection
québecoise monsieur le goût qui
demandait un mandat fort pour rapatrier
plus de pouvoir en immigration tout à
coup il a son mandataire il est demande
plus il dit ben non là je vais essayer
d'utiliser mieux les pouvoirs que j'ai
que j'ai déjà c'est quand même une
victoire politique considérable pour
Justin Trudeau sur ce plan-là et puis la
question de la langue française aussi
est-ce qu'ils vont en parler il y a des
désaccords là-dessus monsieur le goût
lit les deux questions l'immigration et
le déclin du français monsieur Trudeau
moins alors j'imagine que ça aussi il va
y avoir des discussions ce qui va parler
du troisième lien aussi je sais pas
on l'avait presque oublié
justement on l'avait oublié ok on
reviendra ça on en repars
qui nous attend faut pas l'oublier
sécurité des piétons parlant de voiture
sécurité des piétons bon on a tous suivi
cette malheureuse histoire de cette
jeune Maria 7 ans partenaire fauché à
mort par une automobiliste le centre sud
ça aussi c'est documenté depuis deux
jours on l'explique le centre sud
contenu du pont et moins et moins pourvu
en mesure sécuritaire pour les piétons
et moins de Saïd trottoir moins de dos
d'âne parce que on n'avait peur pour
plein de raisons mais entre autres et
même la mairesse ou le reconnaissait
hier vous allez être les premiers à nous
dire il y a des il y a de la il y a pas
de fluidité si je mets trop de si je
mets trop de scie bon il faut faire
attention là écoutez là aujourd'hui je
pense que le résolument et sont partis
faut dire depuis toujours et plutôt de
ce côté-là mais le résolument choisi des
mesures plus agressives pour sécuriser
les piétons on écoute
que dans Ville Marie avant que ce soit
moi c'était Denis koder le mari Denis
koder refusait systématiquement d'envie
de Marie qu'on mette des dos d'encre
quelconque signalisation parce que
c'était pas bon pour la fluidité alors
je vous en prie avant de nous lancer une
pierre alors qu'en ce moment les gens
souffrent et tout le monde se pose des
questions je vous faites vous un examen
de conscience de l'autre côté parce que
vous étiez les premiers à dire pendant
la campagne faut pas plateau wiser
Projet Montréal puis votre plateauiser
toute la ville ben vous savez quoi moi
je suis fière qu'au plateauisme enfin ça
veut dire qu'on met la sécurité en haut
de la liste contrairement à vous
alors oui je vais plateauiser toute la
ville dit-elle mais elle le dit
maintenant en disant on va s'assumer et
on va le faire au centre sud on aurait
peut-être dû le faire avant de façon
plus agressive à l'être
ouais
dans son propre but pour reprendre des
termes de la Coupe du monde de soccer
parce que l'attaquer Projet Montréal sur
quelque chose qu'on juge est une force
du parti peut-être pas la meilleure idée
au monde mais oui il y a un progrès des
progrès qui ont été faits dans les
dernières années dépendamment des
quartiers plus rapidement que d'autres
moi j'ai vécu une partie des dernières
années dans Rosemont petite patrie on a
eu beaucoup de saillies de trottoirs qui
sont ajoutés de d'arestop aussi il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'endroits on a ajouté
des dos d'Orne encore que les dos d'âne
là les experts sont pas c'est pas sûr
que c'est nécessairement une bonne idée
puisque les véhicules accélèrent les
experts résistent toujours que c'est pas
une bonne idée mais c'est drôle dans les
quartiers où les gens sont plus riches
il y en a partout des dos d'ânes moi la
mairesse me répondait ça il y a je
regrette mais un dos dans c'est un fait
c'est pas une opinion
dedans on doit ralentir avec non tu
ralentis avant de réaccélérer ça dépend
où ils sont
le fait que ça soit surélevé sur les
coins de rue tout ça et généralement
plus efficace mais coûte un peu plus
cher
mais oui parce qu'on voit les voitures
on peut voir les voitures qui arrivent
oui on voit on voit les piétons qui
s'approchent parce que les saillies
trottoirs se rapproche les piétons on
les voit dans notre champ de vision ça
raptisse la route les voitures
ralentissent bref mais c'est plus cher
et c'est un peu plus long à mettre en
place mais ça pour dire que des
quartiers qui se sont beaucoup améliorés
dans les dernières années et d'autres
comme Ville Marie quartier du
centre-ville ou en périphérie il y a
quand même beaucoup de gens qui vivent
ça a été beaucoup plus long et c'est
encore plus long on est peut-être
effectivement rendu là parce que il y a
bien des endroits où on a besoin et ça
en plus avec le pont le pont tunnel la
fontaine qui est fermé il y a plus de
d'automobilistes qui passent par Jacques
Cartier donc qui passe par certains
coins de rue à chalandais en raison des
écoles et là on se retrouve avec avec
une congestion qui est plus importante
que d'habitude et le centre sud dans le
Journal de Montréal ce matin ils ont
corrigé les chiffres par quartier puis
c'est le quartier où ça va moins il y a
eu plus de collision piéton voiture en
disant que dans codes Notre-Dame de
Grâce qui est beaucoup plus populaire
donc centre sud oui le parti de la
mairesse était plus proactif mais il y a
du chemin à faire José
oui moi je me serais peut-être garder
une situation du côté de la mairesse
après un événement aussi tragique parce
que là c'était vraiment de la politique
très très partisane sa sortie
d'aujourd'hui
madame plante et mairesse de est à son
deuxième mandat leur avais pas juste
d'arriver là donc
les citoyens des environnements des
environnements ou cet accident tragique
là est survenue se plaignent depuis
longtemps c'est ce qu'ils ont dit ils
ont sonné l'alarme à plusieurs reprises
et on ne les a pas écoutés et là tout à
coup aujourd'hui après cette fait dire
que tout ça était très compliqué que
c'était long que c'était difficile que
c'était coûteux là il y a une petite
fille de 7 ans qui perd la vie dans un
accident effrayant et là tout à coup
pouf dans le même coin des voleurs
apparaissent des sahiti des choses
apparaissent que les ce qu'on voit les
classes
citoyens depuis des années que c'était
trop compliqué que c'était long que
c'était ceci que c'était cela sous aussi
la mer est splende donc est-ce que ça va
servir de leçon à l'avenir je le sais
pas moi je suis pas très optimiste dans
le genre le son apprises là même après
des tragédie mais vraiment là j'ai
trouvé ça un petit peu gênant
aujourd'hui comme comme démonstration
c'est de réconcilier la sécurité d'un
côté la fluidité de l'autre et on a eu
l'impression dans certains quartiers que
la mairesse la ville avait peur de de
bloquer la fluidité de se le faire
reprocher là je pense ça ça peut être
aussi ça vient de changer ça ben oui
mais là il s'appelait la mort d'un
enfant là c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est
sur canne dans tout ça et le centre sud
je m'excuse mais que ce soit sous
monsieur Kader ou sous-marin si depuis
longtemps quartier qui est négligé qui
est même parfois abandonné par les
pouvoirs publics là moi il pour le
savoir alors franchement peut-être qu'on
si l'administration plante pouvait
redécouvrir l'existence du centre sud et
vraiment ça occuper ce serait déjà ça de
prix mais
vraiment le monter de remonter à blâmer
de Nicolas qui et oui on peut blâmer
mais comme je dis je pense que
l'important c'est la parole des citoyens
de ce coin-là qui ont sonné l'alarme à
plusieurs fois et qui n'ont pas été
écoutés et comme toujours trop souvent
ça prend un drame comme vous dites pour
changer les choses moi j'ai qu'une seule
enfant sur ma rue dans une audune il y a
un enfant décédé pouvant être et après
il y a eu deux stops une lumière puis
bon c'est malheureux Alec est-ce qu'on a
besoin de rappeler les éboulements aussi
là
l'accident tragique des éboulements ça a
pris tous ces morsures pour que enfin la
route soit refaite
merci à vous merci Alec j'ai pris votre
temps je suis allée Alex vous leur donne
la prochaine fois et bon match je vous
reparle pour vous vous êtes un fan je
vois ce passé de foot ok merci à vous
deux oui une soirée au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici